hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel what today i just wanted to
make a quick video to talk about the ai
in death loop and a lot of the
conversation that i've seen surrounding
the ai in death loop um
including me i guess i made a preview
video when i got access to the game
you know a month or so ago um where i
basically spoke about
the ai being what i would say
sort of bad um the fact that i can just
kind of do that and then if i just run
away
they'll give up on pursuing me really
really fast um they're also really easy
to kill it's not difficult to kill every
single npc in a level
um i'm in up dom at noon right now and i
actually have managed to do that in this
level i've killed everybody here
more than once and it's not difficult to
do um
and while i think that i may have used
the word bad when i made that video
that is not the correct word and i feel
like that is part of the broader
conversation about deaf loop um when i
spoke about it before i did say again
yeah she's just completely
given up on me real fast and it wasn't
even hard to run away from you know it's
just it's not very punishing she'll
probably just walk back there
you can just do that and nobody else
even heard anything
but uh
yeah even when i made that first video i
did say
there is a reason that the
ai and death loop is like this and
ultimately yeah my thing that i want to
touch on is is sort of a little bit
about the way that ai works that i think
maybe a lot of people don't know based
on the the conversations here um so i
don't think that it is actually bad that
is a wrong word to use in terms
of how it's balanced with the rest of
the game um the fact that they can't see
me would be very unusual in dishonored
i'm just gonna do that we're just gonna
walk back up here
but death loop is a game that is very
much focused
on um this giant puzzle that you're
trying to solve in tracking down your
leads right now it just wants me to to
exit this level
um and making sure that you figure out
how to take down each of the
um
visionaries in a single loop
basically if you were trying to do that
with ai that would chase you down and
would hunt you down the same way that
they do in dishonored for example i
think that the the balance of the whole
game would be thrown off the game would
be nowhere near as good um it would it
would be frustrating uh a lot of people
would probably give up on trying to
solve the loop at all um which is
obviously your singular purpose in this
game it is not about trying to stealth
past enemies you can blow through
through them and i appreciate that about
this game that it plays differently
to um dishonest and certainly different
to pray too uh but what i wanted to talk
about today you know outside of having
said the things that i've already said
is
the
uh
parts of this discussion that i've seen
where people are essentially saying
the ai in this game is bad as though
arcane doesn't know how to make
a.i um
so for context and i i certainly assume
that this is the case with arcane as it
is for
every other video game that i'm aware of
uh
the ai knows where the player is 100 of
the time
that's that's your starting point the
the every single npc in the level every
single enemy that you're going to come
across knows where you are
100 of the time
the tweaking of that comes into play
with
i'm just going to do that run away again
i'm just gonna use this gameplay to
repeatedly show the issues
or the thing that i'm talking about
um
the balance is in actually dialing that
back and deciding the circumstances upon
which the ai will investigate where the
player is how they will react to the
player when they will engage in combat
when they will give up that's what is
actually the process it's not
none of these people have any idea where
cult is in the level and we need to move
that upwards in increments to make them
smarter it's actually that the ai is the
smartest knows absolutely everything is
running on the same code as cult and has
to be dialed and tweaked backwards and i
think that's the part of the
conversation that especially is someone
who very early mentioned issues with
the ai and thinking that some people
would find them to be uh dumb is that
it's not actually something that arcane
has done
by accident by any means
just not aiming at that very well
it is entirely
intentional um i feel like again
dishonest uh even frey
demonstrate that really well and that
you know they they do have ai that can
hunt you down it can be really really
punishing and can make it difficult to
get through things if you don't stealth
so what they've done here is go from the
100 that i'm talking about and dial it
um back not dial it forward they have
not made a mistake what they've done as
a studio who are
very good about creating uh punishing
stealth in other video games
is
change death loop to make it so that
they will be
pursuing you a lot less actively because
that is not the purpose of the game
um that is my main thesis here is that
while bad i think is again a word that i
use it's a really easy way to describe
this kind of ai meaning that you know
they're really easy to get away from
they don't act like people would you can
kill every single one of them without
too much of a challenge you can run away
you can duck behind a corner all of that
is is quite simple
the point is that they didn't do that by
creating dumb ai the ai is fantastic
and has been
reduced from 100 knowing where the
player is um to make sure that death
loop plays as the game it is intended to
be which is really
a smart puzzle game um it's a game where
you have to chase the breadcrumbs again
right now it's leading me towards the
exit figure out where everyone is
it is not a game about taking down every
npc to stealth your way through a level
like dishonored is so
it's it's very very very intentional
they've not made a mistake and so i
don't think the criticism is necessarily
fair
while yeah they are stupid
again it's not the right word
technically they're not stupid they know
exactly where you are and have a bunch
of contingencies to prevent them from
just trying to pursue you all the time
and it feels that way on a surface level
um i ultimately just think it's a very
basic criticism that that's
not to say that you know if you you wish
they were a little bit harder that i
think that that's invalid that's totally
fair but i'm just seeing people you know
use the words bad and dumb and stupid
as though arcane made a mistake but the
point that i'm trying to make is that
this is clearly really really really
really intentional um it is
the purpose
of the npcs in this game of the people
that i'm shooting throughout this video
with a tremendous amount of ease
they serve a very different purpose to
an ai in call of duty they serve a very
different purpose to
um enemy ai in again dishonored in prey
in in any of arcane's other works um and
the works of other stealth games as well
um and
while i would think the ai is not even
as difficult as hitman when you are
facing
uh such
a big through line i think even having
it be as aggressive as it is in hitman
which is you know not dissimilar in
terms of your inside of a sandbox trying
to follow the breadcrumbs that are
pretty readily handed out to you
um
hitman still feels really contained this
is one big picture and i just feel like
they they would have done the play
testing they would have done focus
testing even for this they would have
had people tinker with this over and
over and over again
to get to the point where it wasn't
incredibly frustrating for people to try
to solve the puzzle to try to focus on
the main story focus on the main quest
and actually
get through what is the purpose of the
game
um which yeah i imagine would have been
way way way too too difficult if it were
dishonest levels of difficult um
or dishonored levels of of
you know ai engagement ai pursuing you
um it's just a very different thing so
i i feel like it is yeah it's it's an
easy thing to say it's dumb thus the
game is bad but i think the reality is
actually the opposite is that the ai
is not aggressive in pursuing the player
because
arcane understands fundamentally what
the purpose of death loop is they want
to keep you on track with the purpose of
death loop as in following these leads
tracking down the visionaries and also
keeping the loops fun so that you're
still upgrading so that you can still
take out the visionaries um to upgrade
your nexus labs to upgrade your weapons
or whatever else
it's not dumb it is a very intentional
choice that makes the game satisfying to
play
that makes it fun for you to repeat
levels is probably the biggest thing
while there are in theory 16 maps
because of the day night cycle creating
you know 16 different
stages overall um and i feel like it's
so clear that that some of this design
uh for these levels came from um the
wolfenstein
uh game that they also worked on
um
yeah if if the ai were too aggressive
again there's no way they didn't balance
this and didn't think about this it's
not some programmer has made a mistake
um it was probably really frustrating to
get through them over and over and over
again and to to intentionally make some
of the mistakes that you are
sort of supposed to make
um and i have absolutely just just no
doubt that they knew that so i just
think we're kind of coming at it from
the wrong angle is sort of my point here
um i think that
it is
it is ai that was 100 aware of where the
player was
like you really should know where i am
and because they don't feel like the
behavior patterns of real people it just
it feels off and i'm not gonna yeah tell
anyone they're wrong for that criticism
but i do think the criticism is coming
from
the wrong place essentially
they they definitely know what they're
doing and have created a really balanced
game that i don't think feels
frustrating loot by loop that doesn't
get
um annoying because you're being killed
uh just for trying to figure out one
little tiny thing that that leads into
this bigger picture it is a very clear
balance from a studio who has definitely
made games where the ai is much much
much more punishing um it's supposed to
feel a lot more like your playground you
really are the main character of the
loop when you play as cult um
and yeah i think that's that's kind of
my point here is you know i feel like
we should maybe just have a little bit
more a little bit more faith yeah i
think i did use the word bad in my first
video
my point here is that i feel like bad is
a really reductive way to talk about
this and i probably shouldn't have used
the word bad but it also feels like such
an easy way to express the point of like
they don't react to you like real people
would
but that's not bad it is definitely
intentional and i think they've made the
right choice
uh overall i still think this game is
absolutely fantastic and yeah i just
wanted to make this quick video to talk
about that one particular thing because
i feel like so much of this conversation
specifically uh people are getting
caught up in um
at least in in some cases i'm definitely
not going to shoot this of everyone they
seem to assume that ai starts at zero
and then is slowly ramped up and that
they fail to ramp it up where actually
ai starts at 100 they know where the
player is 100 of the time
and you have to figure out how to layer
that backwards it's not the other way
around if that makes sense so
yeah i hope you guys enjoyed this video
i hope everything here uh makes sense
and i wasn't too rambly
[Laughter]
and i will see you guys next time bye